hello is it me you're looking for I can
see it in your eyes this is the kind of
stuff I do a lot periscopes all the time
anyway for those of you guys are going
to be in rhode island on saturday myself
minion cell are going to have a panel at
twelve o'clock and we'd love it if you
guys came by it's going to be like a
live episode of the weekly poll podcast
which is the reason why we didn't do it
this week because we're doing it on
Saturday and so the awesome of you guys
came and hung out but for those of you
guys who don't get a chance to make it
to the panel if you're going to be
around the comic-con hopefully we run
into you and will be like hey what's up
and you'll be like hey what's up and
then we'll chill and we'll have fun and
we'll talk about comics and it'll be
awesome so anyway hopefully we'll see
you guys there this coming Saturday and
yeah I will catch you guys later peace